je vais maintenant laisser le micro à
mon ami et collègue Alain Joyandet qui
va diriger la 3ème table
ronde qui va s'achever donc dans à peu
près 1 heure 1h10 avant le discours de
Nicolas Sarkozi al à toi moi je
reviens
minuteséléphone laisse pu à cé de toi et
je reviens dans 5
minutesok bien merci merci beaucoup pour
la qualité des des
débats nous allons donc entamer cette 3è
table ronde dont on dit qu'elle devrait
être un peu la Table Ronde des
solutions même si les solutions contenu
des constats qui ont été faits tout à
l'heure semble assez difficile à trouver
mais il faut s'y attaquer alors pour
cette trè table ronde je vais demander à
Nadia amour qui est notre secrétaire
nationale à l'intégration de nous
rejoindre elle va nous parler de
l'espace
méditerranéen je vais demander aussi à
Kumba diukané qui est chef d'entreprise
et qui est aussi élu républicaine
adjointe au maire d'Évreux de nous
rejoindre avec elle nous allons parler
d'Afrique
euh madame Marie Béatrice Levau qui est
au CIS et qui est référente francophonie
et puis évidemment euh
Joë vient nous rejoindre Joë Garo MAM
qui est sénatrice des Français de
l'étranger établie hors de France et qui
est notre secrétaire national à la
Francophonie vous voyez que cette table
ronde respecte par rapport au précédent
parfaitement la parité que je me sens
même un peu seul
c'est
incroyable et donc je vais appeler
Renaud Girard parce que j'ai besoin
d'être en compagnie est-ce qu'il est là
Renaud Girard
je ne le vois pas il est pas encore
arrivé j'espère qu'il va nous rejoindre
euh je vois quelqu'un arriver c'est
peut-être lui non c'est pas lui voilà et
puis euh Michel
Duclot Michel Ducla monsieur Ducla
installez-vous Michel Ducla qui est
directeur général de l'Académie
diplomatique internationale et qui lui
va nous parler de
dissuasion nucléaire de comment on peut
gagner euh contre le terrorisme et si
Renault Girard revient il nous parlera
lui euh des euh des fameuses le voilà
peut-être Monsieur
Girard parfait euh Monsieur Girard qui
est grand reporter avec lequel on
parlera des euh interventions
extérieures euh de de la France ce
fameux dilemme doit-on y aller ou
doit-on euh rester chez nous euh alors
dans le cadre des des
solutions on voit bien que la
Méditerranée est un endroit qui
concentre beaucoup des sujets beaucoup
des problèmes qui ont été abordés ce
matin vous vous rappelez que Nicolas
Sarkozi avait fait la
promotion donc de cette Union pour la
Méditerranée on peut dire qu'il l'avait
un peu inventé aussi il avait inventé le
G20 mais il avait inventé aussi l'Union
pour la Méditerranée qui était un grand
projet qui reste sans doute d'actualité
euh qui est un peu en panne on va en
parler un peu en panne parce que après
ce ce grand lancement à Paris de l'Union
pour la Méditerranée vous vous rappelez
avec plus de 40 chefs d'État à l'époque
et bien il y a eu un certain nombre de
révolutions il y a eu les printemps
arabes donc l'Union pour la Méditerranée
s'est vu s'est vu freiner et donc Nadia
je vais faire comme Pierre je vais te
donner 5 petites minutes euh et oui 5
petites minutes pour nous dire
simplement où on est euh l'Union pour la
Méditerranée euh petit bilan d'étapes
comment est-ce qu'on peut faire
éventuellement pour la relancer tu vas
prendre ce micro et et voilà donc je je
suis obligé de déclencher le chronomètre
puisque vous savez qu'à midi Nicolas
Sarkozi va venir nous rejoindre et que
bien évidemment il faudra que chacun
puisse avoir c'est oui mais comme je
souhaite qu'après il puisse y avoir
aussi des échanges que ce soit pas une
succession d'intervention donc dans un
premier temps je vous demande de tenir
un propos liminaire de 5 minutes et s'il
nous reste du temps évidemment on
reviendra les uns et les autres avec un
peu d'interactivité comme on dit
aujourd'hui Nadia c'est à toi merci
Alain mais tu as mis les pieds dans le
plat avec le projet d'Union pour la
Méditerranée inventé créé par Nicolas
Sarkozi donc bonjour et merci à tous
d'être nombreux aujourd'hui pour évoquer
ces questions internationales qui sont
absolument essentielles pour la France
puisque je suis convaincue que pour
qu'elle aille mieux il faut aussi
qu'elle soit visible à l'extérieur et
qu'elle soit en capacité d'assumer son
message universitaire alors moi j'ai
universel excusez-moi je vais comment
dire je suis spécialiste de la région
euroméditerranéenne je suis docteur en
histoire et spécialiste sur cette région
je vais pas vous faire un cours
d'histoire je vais pas vous faire subir
cette chose-là mais je vais vous
raconter une petite histoire et vous
faire peut-être partager un souvenir que
j'ai eu ça se passait le 13 juillet 2008
euh le jour du fameux lancement de cette
Union pour la Méditerranée j'étais alors
à la maison derrière mon petit écran
comme la plupart des français et du
monde je l'espère à cette époque et j'ai
été frappée j'ai été vraiment saisie
d'émotion parce que j'avais le sentiment
de vivre vraiment un événement
historique pour la première fois tu l'as
dit Alain 44 pays étaient réunis ce
jour-là pour tenter de relever ce
formidable défi celui de faire de la
Méditerranée un espace de paix et de
prospérité partagée alors certes il y a
eu des expériences il y a eu les
politiques méditerranéennes de l'Union
européenne il y a il a eu le processus
euroméditerranéen de Barcelone qui a eu
le bilan que l'on sait c'est-à-dire
extrêmement mitigé l'idée de Nicolas
Sarkozi et c'était une idée extrêmement
novatrice une idée qui a germé dans son
esprit alors même qu'il n'est pas qu'
n'était pas encore élu président de la
République l'idée c'était de sortir de
cette logique nord- sudud de coopération
avec les pays de laarive sud de la
Méditerranée et de s'inscrire dans un
dans un partenariat véritablement
équilibré gagnant gagnant entre les deux
de la Méditerranée c'est une approche
constructive qui euh s'appuyait sur euh
le principe de solidarité de projets
concrets à l'image des débuts de la
construction européenne avec la C
souvenez-vous en 1951 et Robert Schumann
un des un des pères fondateurs de
l'Europe l'avait aussi signalé voilà tel
et tel projet j'avais été aussi frappé
par la ferveur qui avait qui qui avait
rempli en fait tous les acteurs qui
étaient présents ce jour-là et frappé
aussi par cette image que j'ai encore en
tête celle de Nicolas Sarkozi qui a
embrassé les deux protagonistes
essentiels du conflit
israelllo-palestinien à savoir à
l'époque kouolmert est le président de
l'Autorité palestinienne et ça c'était
extrêmement beau et ça avait suscité
énormément d'espoir et de de comment
dire de joie aussi dans les pays de la
sud de la Méditerranée et aussi en
Europe c'était aussi un partenariat qui
était essentiel parce qu'il affirmait
notre identité commune basée sur des
valeurs communes et sur une histoire
commune par agé depuis des millions
d'années euh pour la première fois aussi
on avait invité à la table des des
discussions la Syrie de affz etassade
alors on avait entendu les commentaires
à l'époque comment on va inviter la
Syrie mais c'est pas possible et ceetera
moi je suis convaincu que Nicolas
Sarkozi avait raison parce que quand on
fait de la politique il faut avoir du
courage et quand on veut construire
l'Union pour la Méditerranée il faut
aussi compter avec tous les pays
riverins de la Méditerranée sans
exception c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera
à trouver des
solutions le projet a été lancé en 2008
des comment dire de nombreux projets ont
été réalisés notamment dans le domaine
environnement avec les les panneaux
solaires méditerranéens les autoroutes
de la mer le développement durable et
cetera le problème c'est que comme vous
le savez 2010-21 on a eu des
bouleversements politiques énormes sur
l'Arve sud de la Méditerranée dans les
pays arabes avec les printemps arabes et
c'est vrai que ça a ten soit peu
bouleverser la dynamique ceci étant on
aurait pu si on avait donné du sens à
cette Union pour la Méditerranée si les
socialistes et François Hollande avaient
su euh avaient su décrypter le message
fondamental qui était derrière cette
organisation on aurait pu se mettre
autour de la table discuter trouver des
solutions pragmatiques notamment pour la
question dramatique des des des migrants
qui ont été par milliers à mourir dans
la Méditerranée qui est aujourd'hui
devenu un cimetière intolérable
inaccepttable on aurait pu donc trouver
aussi des solutions pour la paix le
problème c'est que encore une fois comme
François Hollande l'a fait pour la
plupart des mesures qui ont été qui ont
été portées par Nicolas Sarkozi tout ça
a été rayé de la carte par pure
idéologie l'UPM a été vidé de sa
substance on a même voulu tenez-vous
bien supprimer l'Union pour la
Méditerranée l'Union pour la
Méditerranée François Hollande avait
juste oublié que c'était pas juste un
projet franco-français mais que c'était
un projet qui appartenait désormais à
l'Europe donc on a frisé le ridicule
mais on s'est on s'est un peu rattrapé
euh tout ça pour vous dire que donc
l'Union pour la Méditerranée est
porteuse de promesses qui trouve et ce
seront mes trois points que je vais
aborder très très brièvement Alain
fais-moi confiance euh trouve ces
justifications à la fois dans le passé
dans le présent et dans le futur dans le
passé d'abord juste vous dire que
l'espace méditerranéen est oublié depuis
est habité depuis des millions d'années
depuis la préhistoire c'est dans cette
partie du monde que l'homme a inventé
l'art l'écriture l'alphabet qui est né
au 14e siècle avant notre ère sur les
rives de la Syrie actuelle
et c'est aussi le lieu où ont émergé les
premières villes notamment Jéricho qui
se trouvve aujourd'hui en Israël c'est
pourquoi Paul Valée au début du 20e
siècle avait raison de décrire l'espace
méditerranéen comme une matrice
civilisationnelle comme un espace comme
une machine à faire de la civilisation
et ces empreintes de la civilisation on
les voit aujourd'hui dans dans tous les
paysages méditerranéens et dans toutes
les monuments dans toute l'architecture
c'est une histoire qui a été aussi
marquée par des textes fondateurs je
rappellerai juste au passage le code de
mourabi l'almagesse de ptoléé la
République de Platon le Cantique des
cantiques et j'en passe et des meilleurs
c'est aussi le berceau de la naissance
des trois grandes religions
monothéistes le le le judaïsme le
christianisme et l'islam l'UPM trouve
aussi sa justification dans le présent
pourquoi quand on regarde aujourd'hui ce
qui se passe en Méditerranée c'est le
lieu de toutes les instabilités et de
tous les danger on a eu l'occasion de le
dire lors des tablesrondes précédentes
en Grèce par exemple sur la rive nord de
la Méditerranée année on a eu une
situation où on a failli provoquer un
séisme financier européen et mondial
l'Espagne on ne sait pas où ça va avec
avec podemos le Portugal est aujourd'hui
à la recherche d'un nouveau souffle la
France le chômage de masse une absence
de perspective et une comment dire une
croissance et une compétitivité en
pointiller sur la rive sud c'est pas
mieux c'est même beaucoup plus grave la
Syrie est en ruine aujourd'hui le Liban
est à la recherche d'un gouvernement
avec le spectre de la de la guerre
civile qui pèse toujours sur les
Libanais l'IRAC c'est le chaos l'Égypte
convulse la Libye peine à se relever la
Tunisie est sur la voie de la transition
mais c'est un chemin encore semé
d'embûche notamment d'embûche islamiste
et les autres pays retiennent leur
souffle la problématique actuelle
aujourd'hui vraiment le gros problème de
la Méditerranée on l'a aussi signé c'est
le terrorisme islamiste il faut conclure
je vais conclure la France ok donc la
France dans ce comb combat contre
l'islamistme contre le terrorisme a un
rôle à jouer j'en suis convaincu
notamment ce rôle passe par la la
protection des chrétiens d'Orient des
chrétiens d'Orient qui ont été un
élément significatif de l'histoire du
monde arabe qui ont été à la pointe de
laïisation pardon qui ont pour la
première fois inscrit dans leur
constitution merci Nadia merci et très
bien bon j'espère avoir l'ion form vous
avez vu qu'elle est passionnée mais à un
moment donné je suis hélas obligé de
faire tomber le le le cou près euh je
voudrais qu'on consacre un peu de temps
à
l'Afrique je voudrais
essayer en quelques instants de cadrer
ce que nous avons fait sur l'Afrique et
je voudrais remercier tous ceux qui ont
participé aux différentes réunions que
nous avons organisé ici d'ailleurs au
Républicain un certain nombre de membres
de la diaspora africaine sont ici vous
avez entendu Jean-Paul tout à l'heure
lors de la la première table ronde euh
nous avons aussi travaillé avec les
ambassadeurs africains à Paris je salue
encore d'ailleurs des membres de la
diaspora qui arrivent euh des avocats
des chefs d'entreprisees conseil en
communication
euh des gens qui appartiennent aux
institutions également et je veux
remercier évidemment Kumba euh duukané
qui est ici avec laquelle nous avons euh
coordonné les travaux cher Pierre pour
essayer de de de tracer quelques grandes
lignes euh pour ce qui pourrait être
euh une nouvelle politique une nouvelle
relation avec le continent africain euh
l'ambassadeur Simon ici présent a
également travaillé à nos côtés avec un
autre ambassadeur également français à
Madagascar qui avait été mon directeur
de cabinet lorsque j'étais au
secrétariat d'État donc on a fait un
travail de groupe pour essayer de de de
définir ce que pourrait être cette
nouvelle relation avec l'Afrique c'est
très compliqué pourquoi parce que euh ça
a été dit tout à l'heure j'y reviens pas
l'image de la France en Afrique pour
l'instant n'est pas bonne il faut
appeler un chat un chat y compris auprès
des nouvelles et surtout auprès des
nouvelles générations alors pourquoi on
va pas non plus battre notre coupe
toujours se culpabiliser enfin on a on a
une difficulté parce que quand on
s'occupe beaucoup de l'Afrique alors on
nous on nous dit qu'on est les les les
anciens coloniaux puis quand on s'en
occupe pas on nous dit qu'on se qu'on se
désintéresse du coup il y a une espèce
d'hésitation permanente depuis longtemps
et la conclusion elle est la conséquence
est assez simple c'est qu'on avait avant
10 % de part de marché dans les
investissements étrangers en Afrique et
aujourd'hui on est tombé à 4,7 %. dans
un continent qui représentera en 2050
plus de 2 milliards d'habitants dont 60
% de la population aura moins de 26 ans
un continent qui est à 12 km de l'Europe
par le par Gibraltar et dans lequel on
trouve des concurrents redoutables vous
avez parlé de la Chine tout à l'heure je
je vous confirme que quand on a en face
de nous la Chine ça a été un de mes
premiers euh étonnements quand j'ai j'ai
été nommé au gouvernement d'arriver à
Darel salam et de constater que le lycée
français du tourisme à Darel salam payé
à 100 % par la France était construit
par la Chine qui avait récupéré le
marché parce qu'on a cette fameuse aide
d'élit
dans les dans les parce que Pierre tu as
dit un truc qui est vraiment vrai c'est
la naïveté sortons de la naïveté moi je
ne savais pas en tant que membre du
gouvernement français en Afrique je ne
savais jamais qui j'avais en face de moi
quand on me parlait des asiatiques on me
disait c'est une entreprise chinoise non
c'était pas une entreprise chinoise et à
Darel salam le bateau est arrivé avec la
main d'œuvre les grues les produits je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas trouvé d'entreprise
en fait j'avais en face de nous le
gouvernement
chinois et nous on avait des entreprises
françaises avec des cabis facilement
identifiables qui répondaient aux appels
d'offres et qui était battu par par les
Chinois avec notre argent donc une des
une des façons de de faire dans l'avenir
il va falloir aussi revenir là-dessus
alors qu'est-ce qui sort de nos travaux
pour refonder totalement cette relation
avec l'Afrique c'est sortir de cette
relation paternaliste post-coloniale euh
de de d'apport d'apporteurs d'ê sociale
pour essayer de de d'entrer dans une
nouvelle relation
économique une relation partenariale
d'égal à égal c'est une c'est un
objectif qui est très ambitieux mais en
tout cas c'est ce que nous voudrions
pouvoir faire et en plus les Africains
ne veulent pas qu'on leur impose ils
veulent que on le fasse avec eux et ils
ont raison la diaspora ici présente nous
dit nous on peut aider on peut apporter
et beaucoup sachez que ce que la
diaspora envoie en Afrique comme argent
est plus important que la totalité de
l'aide publique au développement donc on
peut pas faire demain le développement
de l'Afrique sans la diaspora donc
première chose essayer d'atteindre cet
objectif global de changer de de changer
de relation et nous nous avons défini
trois orientations principales et je
demanderai tout à l'heure tout de suite
à à Kumba de les détailler première
chose c'est icieux c'est pas facile
essayer de
transmettre petit à petit ce que nous
faisons en Afrique en ce qui concne les
missions régaliennes qui doivent
appartenir à terme à l'Afrique on pense
à la défense on pense à un certain
nombre de choses comme celle-là donc il
faut essayer de transmettre pour sortir
de la relation paternaliste notamment
avec l'Afrique francophone cette mission
régalienne pour que l'Afrique s'acapare
ses missions régaliennes 2uxème objectif
on nous dit énormément souvent
que à cause de cette frilosité française
de ces difficultés à obtenir des visas
pour les étudiants les chercheurs les
chefs d'entreprise et bien du coup les
Africains s'éloignent de la France les
jeunes africains vont dans les écoles
américaines chinoises et du coup demain
ils feront du business avec avec les
Chinois avec les Américains et puis avec
les Français donc deuxième pilier de ce
que nous nous proposons de renouer avec
des accords culturels beaucoup plus
intensifs comme ça a été d'ailleurs le
cas par le passé et notamment en pensant
aussi au rayonnement francophone de la
France en Afrique grâce à
l'Afrique le français va être à nouveau
très parlé dans le monde puisqu'on va
parler de 200 de 200 millions il y aura
200 millions de il il y a 200 millions
de locuteurs francophonees il y en aura
400 millions d'ici 2050 donc 2uxème
grand pilier remettre en place des des
des échanges culturels à la
hauteur de l'importance demain du Contin
continent africain troisème pilier de
cette nouvelle relation que nous
proposons qui est sans doute le plus
important et que volontairement on veut
pas trop mettre en premier pourquoi
parce que c'est compliqué c'est le
développement économique et on sent bien
qu'il y a chez les Africains cette
volonté de partenariat d'égal à égal
donc on parle pas en terme de prise de
part de marché mais on dit on veut un
partenariat économique de développement
d'égal à égal euh dans des associations
franco-africaines les parts de marché ça
sera la conséquence euh mais on la met
pas on la met pas euh en premier ça sera
la conséquence d'une nouvelle relation
avec l'Afrique pour revenir sur ce
continent à une hauteur euh plus
importante que ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui voilà en résumé ce que nous
avons défini avec tous ceux avec
lesquels nous avons travaillé et que
nous proposons au aux républicains pour
être cette ce nouveau partenariat cette
Nou nouvelle relation Nicolas Sarkozi
dit souvent avec l'Afrique il faut tout
changer et c'est vrai qu'il faut tout
changer et donc surtout trouver le
chemin de crête pour arrêter d'être naïf
en même temps faire un partenariat
d'égal à égal et que la conclusion de
tout ça sans le dire mais avec quand
même il faut bien le reconnaître l'envie
de le faire reprendre pied sur le
continent africain et en plus les
Africains le souhaitent il y a une
demande de France à condition que ça se
fasse dans le respect des gales d'égal à
égal vous avez parlé tellement bien des
Russes quand je vois ce que font les
Russes maintenant en Afrique les Turcs
il y a un moment charnière c'est
aujourd'hui c'est 7 8 % de de croissance
sur le continent africain on ne peut pas
être absent de ce qui va se passer en
Afrique dans les 20 ou 30 ans qui
viennent je suis persuadé que ce qui
s'est passé en Asie et qu'on est en
train dont on est en train de constater
les conséquences aujourd'hui et bien
demain ça peut être le tour de l'Afrique
qui n demand demande qu'une chose c'est
à se moderniser c'est être industrialisé
puis enfin il y a un point dont il a été
question tout à l'heure c'est la
démographie c'est pareil on n pas le
droit d'en parler ça sera une
conséquence heureuse on voit que partout
là où il y a du développement économique
et bien il y a une régulation naturelle
de la démographie si on commence à dire
aux
Africains faut faire moins d'enfants
parce que vous pourrez pas faire reculer
la pauvreté si vous avez un taux de
natalité plus fort que le taux de
croissance on leur dit attendez nous
parlez pas de ça nos enfants c'est notre
av IR donc c'est un sujet un peu tabou
donc on en a pas trop fait là-dessus
mais on pense que s'il y a de
l'industrialisation s'il y a du
développement économique mais tout à
fait naturellement il y aura une
régulation démographique comme on le
voit dans les pays modernes voilà donc
les l'essentiel de ce que nous avons
décidé de proposer au républicains mon
cher Pierre et je vais demander donc à
en 5 minutes à Kumba parce que moi j'en
ai fait SEP donc comme j'en ai fait SEP
elle va en faire CIN euh pour détailler
les différents points merci merci euh
merci
Alain je me rends simplement compte que
Alain a résumé nos travaux en 7 minutes
et je dois rentrer dans les détails en 5
minutes donc ça va être un exercice
assez difficile mais merci en tout cas à
à Alain d'avoir animé ce ce groupe de
travail sous la l'œil avisé de Pierre
Lelouche de ERC vert et de toute
l'équipe alors nous avons donc mené ces
travaux avec donc plusieurs personnes
qui sont dans la salle et qu'on remercie
vraiment du fond du cœur et d'autres qui
n'ont pas pu être là comme les
ambassadeurs donc alin a à à résumer en
fait ce que nous avons relevé
effectivement le constat je vais pas
revenir là-dessus de la perte
d'influence économique et culturelle de
la France en Afrique pte d'influence
économique qui a un corelaire direct
avec la perte d'influence culturelle et
comme il vient de le dire lorsque des
jeunes vont suivre des études à
l'étranger lorsque le gouvernement
américain offre 500 bourses pour former
des jeunes africains ces jeunes
africains feront le lobby pour les
entreprises américaines plus tard donc
nous n'avons aujourd'hui euh nous avons
avancé donc sur un certain nombre
d'idées de partenariat gagnant- gagnant
avec l'Afrique tant sur le point de vue
économique sur les missions régalienne
mais aussi du point de vue culturel
alors rapidement sur l'émission
régalienne un sujet a été soulevé qui
est la zone monétaire le franc CFA et
dans cette dans ce passage de relais de
la responsabilité je dirais monétaire
nous avons effectivement constaté la
présence de la France une présence je
dirais très forte dans le conseil
d'administration d'une grande banque qui
est la banque centrale des États de
l'Afrique de l'Ouest qui a été
régulièrement remise en question plus ou
moins par le groupe de travail et l'idée
c'est vraiment de pouvoir imaginer un
conseil des sages à avec des Français
des Européens qui va aider donc cette
monnaie africaine à devenir à être
toujours prospère et toujours présente
mais avec un passage de relais auprès
des Africains on a aussi parlé de du
passage de relais sur le point de vue
sécuritaire effectivement Nicolas
Sarkozi avait à l'époque aider l'Union
africaine à mieux s'organiser du point
de vue de la défense l'idée c'est aussi
de de de progresser en fait dans dans ce
domaine de permettre en fait de faire
plus de prévention que d'action
lorsqu'il y a des des crimes liés par
exemple à euh à au terrorisme la
responsabilité économique nous en avons
aussi beaucoup parlé effectivement nous
sommes en présence d'un continent avec
des pays qui deviennent émergents des
pays qui ont un taux de croissance qui
frolent les deux chiffres et qui ont
beaucoup d'ambition et des pays sur
lesquels interviennent beaucoup de
nationalités différentes nous l'avons
dit la Turquie est très présente la
Chine les Américains et sur lesquels
nous devons aussi arriver avec je dirais
on nous reproche l'arrogance française
parce que nous arrivons en terrain
conquis parce que nous arrivons avec
soitisant des parts de marché qui sont
gagné d'avance et en réalité on se bute
vraiment à la concur internationale donc
comment aujourd'hui peut-on aider la
France à reconquérir le marché africain
mais aussi les Africains à travailler en
parfaite collaboration avec la France la
société civile de la même manière aussi
a a besoin de d'être réorganisé d'une
manière plus conséquente alors sur les
échanges Franco
culturels les jeunes qui représentent
aujourd'hui 70 à 80 % du continent de la
population africaine euh nous avons euh
après la deuxème guerre mondiale créé ce
qu'on appelle un jumelage c'est très
simple qui aidit à la réconciliation
franco-allemande et nous avons imaginé
créer un Erasmus avec les étudiants
africains pourquoi un Erasmus avec les
étudiants africains la population la
plus hostile aujourd'hui à la France ce
sont les jeunes pour la bonne et simple
raison que beaucoup de choses sont
reprochées à la France à savoir par
exemple le soutien de certains certains
chefs d'État et cetera bon beaucoup de
de de choses aussi parce que quand même
on a les réseaux sociaux qui font
beaucoup de mal des fois beaucoup de
bien mais aussi beaucoup de mal tout ce
qui se dit ici et tout de suiteess en
Afrique tout ce qui se fait estess et
donc l'idée c'est de com t'interrompre
mais je vais te demander peut-être de de
comment dire d'aller un petit peu plus
vite dans dans dans l'énoncer des
différentes propositions que que l'on a
fait sur les sur les les deux autres
chapitres qui restent culture et
économie parce que on va prendre du
retard et puis après après on renverra
dans le
détail toute la proposition de notre
groupe de travail qui va faire l'objet
d'une tribune qui sera publiée et qui
sera envoyé d'ailleurs à tous les
adhérents de de de notre parti politique
ce qui doit te permettre normalement de
de de nous donner les différentes
propositions qui sont faites sans trop
rentrer dans le détail pardon de de de
te contrarier j'aurais juste une minute
de plus parce que tu m'as
interrompu
on se croirait à l'Assemblée
nationale tu asire à une femme et à une
francosénégalaise 2 minutes de plus
Pierre alors donc je reprends donc c'est
ce projet d'Erasmus pour les étudiants
donc qui permet que des étudiants
français puissent aller suivre donc un
petit cursus en Afrique et l'inverse que
les étudiants africains puissent venir
de 3 mois en France et s'imprégner de la
culture de la langue et des habitudes et
bien sûr du volet économique la création
du visa francophone qui est destiné aux
chefs d'entreprise aux scientifiques et
aux chercheurs qui permet aussi à ces
ces ces Africains universitaires et
étudiants de venir en France pour
pouvoir y séjourner et cetera la
création de la Maison de l'Afrique alors
la création de la Maison de l'Afrique
qui existe aussi à Londres cette maison
de l'Afrique qui aide simplement à avoir
une bonne visibilité avec beaucoup de
contenu un contenu économique c'est une
maison qui pourrait permettre à des
hommes d'affaires faire d'y venir d'
pouvoir faire des affaires de rencontrer
aussi des des cadres à à la culture de
pouvoir aussi prospérer et cetera donc
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails àin
parce qu'il va encore me alors la la les
instances de gouvernance et de
coopération française en présence de la
diaspora alors ça c'est une demande qui
a été vraiment exprimée par le groupe de
travail effectivement les décisions les
instances de décision et cetera peuvent
associer les personnes issues de la
diaspora qui ont participé au groupe de
travail qui sont là qui sont en France
et cetera et qui permettra de donner un
avis étant à cheval entre la France et
l'Afrique de par leurs
origine ensuite euh ces mesures peuvent
aider à renforcer le recrutement et la
promotion ensuite dernier point le
codéveloppement le renforcement de
l'Agence française pour le développement
aujourd'hui nous l'avons constaté et ça
a été dit depuis ce matin l'aide
publique au développement ne peut plus
continuer à être ce qu'il est
actuellement on ne sait pas comme l'a
dit Pierre Lelouche ce matin où est-ce
que cette aide là où l'argent va et on a
besoin de mieux cibler cette aide
publique au développement pour que ça
aille directement auprès des populations
alors comment le renforcement donc de de
l'agence de l'Agence française de
développement qui va donner une priorité
au partenariat économique on a aussi
parlé de la diplomatie renforcer cette
diplomatie économique qui va permettre
mettre à nos ambassadeurs qui sont à
l'étranger en Afrique de pouvoir
renforcer cette visibilité économique de
la France merci
beaucoup
Kumba j'ajoute qu'il y a vraiment un
point essentiel dans ce qu'elle a dit
sur le développement économique c'est
vraiment une conviction que nous avons
avec Nicolas Sarkozi il faut vraiment
sortir de l'aide sociale parce que les
subventions pour l'aide sociale on sait
très bien qu'il y en a de moins en moins
euh et il faut impérativement faire du
développement économique l'Afrique est
mû pour ça l'AFD quand je suis arrivé au
gouvernement déployer environ 1 milliard
d'euros par an de prêt aux entreprises
soit directement soit par sa filiè
Proparco on est passé rapidement à deux
ou 3 milliards parce qu'on a bien vu
qu'il en fallait beaucoup plus on dit
dans ce projet que l'AFD pourrait
développer un rythme annuel de 15
milliards d'euros en prêt pour financer
du développement économique parce que la
meilleure recette contre la pauvreté
c'est quand même le développement
économique on a fait plein d'expérience
on a implanté des entreprises en Afrique
je me souviens de de ce qu'on avait fait
à Saint-Louis du Sénégal en en
implantant avec un une entreprise de
Marseille une re une une une entreprise
d'agroalimentaire on a créé 15000
emplois sur sur tout un secteur 2 ans 3
ans plus tard il y avait plus de
problèmes sociaux les petites filles all
à l'école il y avait plus les les les
les la santé était présente donc
développement économique c'est du
gagnant gagnant ça peut être fait par
des Français ça peut être fait par des
Africains ça peut être fait par des
entreprises
francoafricaines avec des financements
français du coup l'Afrique va mieux du
coup la pauvreté recule et du coup les
pars de marché françaises sont plus
importantes en Afrique c'est vraiment ça
la priorité des priorités dans dans
l'Afrique de demain pour que la France
ait une place plus
importante en Afrique donc ça c'est
vraiment un point capitale de ce que on
doit de de ce que l'on doit faire et
l'AFD doit devenir comme comme c'est le
cas au Canada dans d'autres grands pays
c'est vraiment l'Agence française de
développement qui doit devenir le bras
armé de la politique française en
Afrique je propose même que d'ailleurs
le directeur général de lafd er rend
secrétaire d'État je candide à rien euh
mais mais voilà pour que ce soit
vraiment pas une administration un peu
indépendante du gouvernement français
mais le président de la République nomme
le directeur général de l'Agence
française de développement il a rendre
secrétaire d'État il a la mission
d'appliquer fidèlement la politique de
la France en Afrique et c'est pas
quelque chose qui est indépendant du
pouvoir politique mais c'est vraiment le
bras armé politique de la nouvelle
politique française en Afrique il y a il
y a aussi une arme politique et puis un
historique c'est la francophonie
venons-en à la Francophonie mesdames si
vous en étiez d'accord on sa pas trop
concerté avant on a pas eu trop le temps
mais je vous demanderais bien de faire 5
minutes chacune sur la francophonie on
va peut-être commencer par notre
secrétaire national il y a deux éléments
essentiels pour moi il y a la
francophonie culturelle il y a notre
présence francophone en Afrique et puis
y a tout ce qui est francophonie
économique donc madame qui êtes au CIS
peut-être que vous vous pourriez vous
nous parler un petit peu plus de la
Francophonie économique
donc dans un premier temps comment va la
francophonie ns tout tout notre réseau
francophone en Afrique dans quel état il
est comment ça va où on en est et
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire 5 minutes
montre en main
je compte sur toi pour me limiter oui tu
as parlé de la Francophonie économique
de la Francophonie culturelle il ne faut
pas oublier non plus la francophonie
politique avec un véritable espace qui
doit être recréé qui n'existe que
quasiment virtuellement et qui sera une
aide dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
bon j'espère avoir le temps d'y revenir
je crois surtout que quand on parle de
francophonie on se heurte à un paradoxe
français parce que la francophonie c'est
un outil extraordinaire pour nous
Français c'est une des solutions pour
notre développement les chiffres ont été
cités 275 millions de francophones
aujourd'hui 800 millions en principe à
l'horizon 2050 mais n'oublions pas que
les chiffres sont trompeurs parce que
pour que nous ayons autant de
francophones à l'horizon 2050 il faut
aussi que nous y mettions les moyens
parce qu'on comptabilise en parlant des
grands pays on parle du Sénégal par
exemple qui est un pays francophone bien
évidemment mais Kumba ne me contredira
sans doute pas dès que vous sortez des
grandes villes plus personne ne parle le
français ou ne parle un français c'est
suffisamment bon de plus en plus de
Français parlent la langue vernaculaire
et ça c'est aussi parce que nous n'avons
pas fait les efforts en terme
d'enseignement de formation de
professeurs et c'est quelque chose
d'absolument
indispensable donc méfions-nous des
chiffres mais profitons de cette
formidable opportunité parce que nous
sommes aussi confronté à ce complexe
français j'ai entendu j'étais entendu
Alain j'ai entendu pierre parler du fait
qu'on nous aime pas en Afrique et ça
c'est aussi un paradoxe parce
qu'effectivement la France est souvent
le Bou émissaire des insuffisances de
certains pays parce que effectivement
vous si vous comparez par exemple de
pays je caricature un petit peu mais le
Bénin et le Ghana qui sont deux pays
côte à côte l'un anglophone l'un
francophone qui ont la même population
la même superficie l'un réussit beaucoup
mieux que l'autre et là encore c'est un
de nos échecs français et c'est ce que
que nous devons faire nous devons
remédier à cette situation et il y a des
moyens de le faire la mise en réseau
comment se fait-il que les j'allais dire
les anglosaxons mais l'Afrique
anglophone est très organisé travaille
beaucoup sur ces concepts de réseau nous
pas suffisamment c'est aussi notre
complexe parce que nous-même nous
parlons de ce colonialisme qui a
effectivement existé mais il faut aussi
voir ce que nous avons fait de bien je
voyage beaucoup je suis sénateur des
Français de l'étranger je peux vous
assurer que dans beaucoup de pays je
vois des infrastructures qui n'ont pas
changer depuis la présence de la France
alors bien
évidemment nous devons aussi être
parfaitement en accord avec notre
histoire mais nous ne devons pas nous
culpabiliser en permanence c'est la même
chose avec la langue française je suis
scandalisée que le français ne soit pas
davantage utilisé par les Français nous
sommes aidés par les Québécois par les
Haïtiens par les Africains qui nous
demande de pratiquer notre langue juste
un tout petit exemple il y a 15 jours
dans une assemblée parlementaire que
Pierre connaît très bien l'Assemblée
parlementaire de l'OTAN nous avions un
intervenant expert français de l'OCDE
dans un pays au Maroc pays francophone
qui nous a fait une conférence en
anglais alors qu'il y avait des
interprètes et que son anglais n'était
peut-être pas le meilleur anglais qui
soit non plus donc arrêtons et là aussi
je trouve que nous devons donner des
lignes directrices pour que nous aidions
ces pays dans une
autre réunion internationale où tout
était en anglais des Africains des
députés africains sont venus me voir
pour me dire bon j'avais dû faire
l'interprétation pour eux mais il me
disaent mais c'est quand même incroyable
que vous Françis français pardon vous ne
vous battiez pas pour votre langue si ça
continue mes enfants que j'ai mis à
l'école française je vais leur faire
apprendre l'anglais alors qu'ils
apprennent l'anglais bien sûr on a tous
besoin d'apprendre l'anglais on a besoin
de se battre pour les deux langues
obligatoires de langues étrangères
obligatoires parce que c'est aussi un
avantage et un avenir pour la France et
les Français mais arrêtons de nous
stigmatiser de nous c'est sur ce coup de
gueule que je vais devoir interrompre
voilà déjà j'avais tellement de choses à
vous dire mais bon je rappelle je
rappelle dans le projet que nous avons
développé dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
que nous proposons aussi la création
d'un visa francophone ça a été abordé
tout à l'heure comme ça comme ça a été
fait dans le dans dans le Common Wells
et où ça marche très bien donc on va on
va regarder tout ça et ça sera l'objet
évidemment de de la nouvelle politique
qui sera mise en œuvre j'en profite pour
saluer l'arrivée de Michel Aliot Marie
qui vient de nous rejoindre ancienne
ministre des Affaires étrangères dont on
nurait pas compris qu'elle ne soit pas
là
aujourd'hui alors la francophonie sous
l'angle sous l'angle économique vous
avez aussi 5 minutes pour nous éclairer
et nous dire toute la puissance qui est
ce vecteur de de la Francophonie pour le
développement
économique merci merci de m'avoir invité
en tant que membre du Conseil économique
sociale environnemental comme quoi il
sert quelquefois à quelque chose en tout
cas il s'agit pardon il s'agit de
Béatrice lev voilà Marie Béatrice
effectivement je suis membre de la
section affaires internationale
européenne au sein du Conseil économique
français je suis je représente également
le Conseil économique et social français
au sein des conseils de l'Union des
conseils économiques francophon lu césif
voilà et dont le président actuellement
est le président Maroc alors j'ai envie
de dire moi pour ouvrir compléter parce
que je pense que ma voisine est très
frustrée également que la francophonie
ne ne passionne pas la France et en fait
le sujet dans lequel nous sommes rentrés
dans la réflexion que il y avait
effectivement un sujet francophonie au
sein du conseil économique social
environnemental il est évidemment par
notre prisme citoyen société civile
parce que c'est notre angle mais il est
aussi par rapport au regard d'une
histoire de la Francophonie globale qui
a oublié un certain nombre de de points
dont finalement la France au sein de la
Francophonie et donc langue sur lequelle
nous travaillons c'est com
redonner à la France une place dans une
francophonie dynamique donc revisiter la
francophonie du 21e siècle oublier un
peu tout ce qui est derrière nous et
regarder devant et dans dans un des
chiffres importants c'est que la
communauté francophone c'est 16 % du PIB
mondial et que la question voilà et que
la question aujourd'hui c'est en quoi la
France qui est quand même vous l'avez
vous le savez tous et vous l'avez dit
j'ai DIRIS une colonne vertébrale
historique à travers la langue mais
c'est pas suffisant c'est pas suffisant
parce qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
véritablement on va dire de puissance de
la France dans la communauté francophone
et qu'on a été vous l'avez dit un peu
pris par le Québec par tout un ensemble
d'autres États qui ont fait de la
Francophonie un sujet politique et donc
au plan économique il nous paraî très
important et d'ailleurs j'ai remarqué
que Laurent vquier avait pris la
présidence de l'association
internationale des régions francophones
il y a très peu de temps il est donc
très important de pouvoir identifier
tous les leviers économiques mais pas
que on a aussi des enjeux de droit
continental actuellement je dirais le
droit
anglo-saxon est en train de prendre la
main sur les grands enjeux du droit et
de la manière dont on légifère le monde
aujourd'hui donc ça dépasse le la
culture ça dépasse la langue ça dépasse
effectivement l'éducation qui est qui
est évidemment le sol SOC le nécessaire
et donc le question elle est à deux
niveaux pour nous au niveau du Conseil
économique qui travaillons sur la
préparation d'un avis pour le début de
l'année 2017 c'est la perte d'influence
ça vous l'avez dit comment on
retravaille des contextes stratégiques
dans de nouveaux domaines que sont
l'économie le droit continental les
échanges européens francophones et la
France dans ces échanges européens
francophones au profit évidemment bien
sûr aujourd'hui du culture que l'on
considère comme étant renfor c'est
anglo-saxon la deuxème et le deuxième
point évidemment c'est l'influence
francophone et l'influence francophone
vous l'avez dit c'est l'éducation c'est
la culture c'est le sport c'est les
droits humains qui sont largement je
dirais engagés par l'OIF n'oublions pas
que l'Organisation internationale de la
Francophonie a son siège à Paris et une
partie de ses financements sont
également français et que on agit de
manière je dirais peut-être un peu plus
faible politiquement au sein de tous ces
enjeux là et donc le ite d'intérêt de
visibilité et d'engagement pour la
francophonie je dirais que en France
c'est plus un objet médiatique je dirais
même c'est un objet médiatique non
identifié la Journée internationale de
la Francophonie qui a lieu au printemps
et en mars fait pas du tout l'objet
d'une reprise intéressante pour nos
concitoyens et finalement la
Francophonie est devenue incomprise pour
les concitoyens et notre angle à nous au
Conseil économique social et
environnemental c'est de se dire que la
France le franceçais a quand même été la
langue de la COP et on voit bien que la
le français est la langue climat parce
que la COP 21 bien sûr mais pas que la
COP 22 au Maroc également et qu'on on
nutilise pas tous ces vecteurs pour
recentrer le sujet et je pense que
depuis des années des dizaines d'années
on a un secrétariat d'État à la
Francophonie et je n'ai rien contre
évidemment monsieur le ministre mais je
pense que dans les pré il y a aussi la
volonté de dire est-ce que dans les
prochains gouvernements par exemple on
aura un ministre délégué à la
Francophonie rattaché au Premier
ministre c'est est-ce qu'on envoie des
signes aux citoyens et nous l'angle que
nous avons c'est comment on réconcilie
les citoyens français la France mais
aussi les citoyens avec un enjeu
francophone qui est effectivement ce que
vous avez dit économique je rappelle
qu'Africa 2016 sera au mois de septembre
dans les murs du Conseil économique
social et environnemental donc on est
extrêmement engagé là-dessus et on est
totalement moi je suis totalement en
phase avec ce que vous avez dit dans vos
propos improductifs mais il faut avancer
maintenant il faut arrêter de passer je
dirais du temps sur l'état des lieux il
faut donner des signe à voir et il faut
embarquer avec nous les Français dans la
francophonie revisiter pour vraiment
redynamiser l'ensemble on est d'ailleurs
pardon je vous interromps mais on est
d'ailleurs preneur de de propositions
très concrètes parce que là on est
toujours dans l'état des lieux mais on
aura l'occasion évidemment de de
travailler encore sur le sujet ici au
républicains ça fait que commencer euh
nous on a fait un un un programme un
projet sur trois piliers pour refonder
nos notre relation avec l'Afrique la
francophonie va bien au-delà de de
l'Afrique bien évidemment enfin c'est
quand même un outil indispensable pour
nous en Afrique je rappelle aussi que
c'est quand même la deuxième langue
officielle de toutes les organisations
de Bruton Woods là aussi il faut se il
faut se battre parce que moi aussi j'ai
constaté quand je représentais le
gouvernement français à nous New York ou
partout que nos nos éminents
représentants français s'exprimaient en
anglais mais il y a pas que ce il y a
pas que ce sujet là je pense que le
sujet est très vaste donc je suis obligé
d'en rester là pour pour aujourd'hui
parce que je voudrais peut-être qu'on va
on aura le temps de revenir après
j'espère alors juste un mot c'est 30
secondes alors comment comment l'ASSÉ
juste un mot bon j'avais beaucoup de
propositions que j'ai pas eu le temps
d'évoquer mais il y a quelque chose qui
me paraît extrêmement important c'est
l'audiovisuel extérieur et c'est un
exemple de tout ce que nous avons dit on
est en train de parler de création d'une
nouvelle chaîne publique d'information à
un coût considérable alors qu'il y a des
tas de chaînes d'information qui
existent avec pas suffisamment de
publicité pour les faire vivre et à côté
de ça on a une chaîne à vocation
internationale France 24 qui est tout à
fait remarquable qui peut nous aider
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme en
faisant passer des messages très forts
et qui se bat pour essayer de bloquer
son budget j'ai fait une tribune
là-dessus mais on sent bien que le
gouvernement est bloqué sur cette
question on a besoin de travailler sur
les outils qui existent plutôt que de
dépenser la gabégie merci merci comme 2
minutes aussi à Kumba avant avant de
conclure sur l'Afrique alors je je vais
peut-être en rajouter à ta colère Joë
parce que quand tu parles de de de la
perte de enfin du français de de de
baisse du du français en Afrique nous ne
pouvons pas avoir une certaine afficher
une certaine politique telle que le
gouvernement socialiste actuel
qui vient de couper les subventions à
l'école franco-sénégalaise à Dakar et
cette école qui va être reprise par des
Turcs ou par des Chinois et les enfants
qui parleront turc chinois on ne peut
pas continuer à se plaindre en affichant
une politique pareille tu parles aussi
d'une chaîne France 24 oui moi je veux
bien mais pour aussi donner une certaine
dynamique et aider aussi les entreprise
française à aller en Afrique donnons une
bonne image de l'Afrique dans
l'audiovisuel nous ne pouvons pas à
montrer que de la misère alors qu'il y a
de bonnes choses qui s'y passent alors
qu'il y a de l'émergence et une bonne
économie merci avant de avant de donner
la parole à nos deux interlocuteurs
avant que Pierre n'aborde son sujet je
veux dire
qu'évidemment la Francophonie est un est
un des sujets en Afrique je veux dire
évidemment que nous abordons l'Afrique
dans sa globalité il y a pas une Afrique
il y a des Afriques c'est clair le
Nigéria évidemment ne fait pas partie du
champ francophone le Nigéria sera demain
en 2050 la trè puissance au monde par sa
démographie derrière l'Inde et et la
Chine avec plus de 500 millions
d'habitants alors que l'Europe va
stagner à 450 et les États-Unis à peu
près la même chose donc on voit bien que
l'Afrique est diverse et qu'il faut
aborder l'Afrique sous ces différentes
facettes et on doit avoir une politique
extérieure vraiment globale pour les
différentes Afriques que nous que nous
avons à aborder alors il y aura aussi
une liaison avec l'Afrique avec Monsieur
Renault Girard qui va nous parler
peut-être maintenant puisqu'on vient de
parler d'Afrique des interventions
extérieur Renault Girard est grand
reporter
international nos interventions
extérieures donnent toujours lieu à
polémique évidemment on nous
remercie à l'étranger quand nous
arrivons pour sauver des démocratie
parfois nos interventions sont
jugées beaucoup plus négativement en
tout cas vous qui avait ce ce regard
d'observateur mondial j'allais dire de
nos interventions extérieures merci de
de de nous en dire ce que vous en pensez
et comment nous devons éventuellement
les les réorienter c'est un sujet très
très vaste et vous n'avez hélas aussi
que 5in minutes pour aborder un peu le
sujet si je fais la moyenne des
interventions ça ça a l'air de faire un
peu plus de 5 minutes mais euh mais
comme à chaque fois que je donne 5
chacun prend se c'est pour ça que je
vous donne 5 euh non d'abord je voudrais
remercier pierre Lelouche de m'avoir
invité je veux vous dire que je suis ému
d'être ici
euh c'est la première fois de ma vie que
je participe à une réunion politique
mais quand j'avais 15 ans j'étais au
lycée louis- Legrand et le général de
Gaul est mort et je suis j'ai décidé
d'aller à son enterrement euh mes
camarades du lycée grand m'ont pris pour
un fou furieux ils étaient soit
gauchistes maoistes soit communistes
mais je suis allé à l'enterrement du
général et donc euh je dirais c'est ma
deuxème manifestation gaulise de ma vie
et c'est pour ça que je suis ému c'est
pour ça que je suis venu je suis jamais
venu dans un dans un parti
politique et vous êtes et vous êtes venu
à quelques jours du 18 juin voilà et euh
la deuxième chose c'est qu'effectivement
j'ai l'honneur pour Le Figaro de couvrir
depuis 35 ans euh toutes les guerres et
toutes les grandes
crises diplomatiques et si j'imagine
pour cela que Pierre Lelouche m'a invité
et tous les mardis je livre dans ma
chronique internationale du Figaro ma
vision des affaires internationales et
de ce que devrait être une politique
étrangère de la France alors sur le thme
des interventions extérieures monsieur
le ministre euh je vous répondrai que
selon moi il y en aura toujours c'est ce
qu'on appelait les interventions
d'humanité avant la guerre de CAD
c'est on appelait ça l'Occident donne
différents mots droit d'ingérence devoir
de protéger les population civile mais
je pense que il est urgent aujourd'hui
d'encadrer strictement les opérations
extérieures de la France pas seulement
d'exiger bien sûr un vote préalable du
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU ce dont
nous nous sommes passés pour le Kosovo
c'est pas ce que nous avons fait de
mieux euh mais des conditions propres
que nous devonss mettre pour nos
opération extérieure la première
condition c'est on vire un dictateur
très bien qui s'appelle Sadam Bachar
caddafi par qui on le remplace a-t-on
une équipe de
remplacement car mesdames et
messieurs mesdames et
messieurs la dictature politique nous ne
l'aimons pas en France et nous avons
raison de ne pas l'aimer nous l'avons
combattu et nous vivons en liberté ça
nous a pris pas mal de temps mais depuis
disons euh 150 ans euh depuis l'Empire
libéral euh mais nous n'aimons pas la
dictature politique mais nous devons
nous souvenir dans notre politique
étrangère qu'il y a pire que la
dictature politique il y a l'anarchie et
il y a pire mesdames et que l'anarchie
il y a la guerre
civile la deuxième condition que je
mettrai pour encadrer nos opérations
extérieures
c'est les populations civiles nous avons
invoquer lorsque nous avons fait
l'opération en Libye nous avons envoyé
notre ministre des Affaires étrangères
Alain Jupé au Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU et pour avoir l'aval du Conseil de
sécurité nous av avons invoqué le droit
et le devoir de protéger les populations
civiles c'est pour cela que nous avons
eu un mandat du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU nous avons nous sommes donc
intervenus
et ensuite les rebelles qui étaient
aidés et armé par nous ont bombardé
férocement une ville qui s'appelait SIRT
qui avait le malheur d'avoir une
population qui était favorable pas à la
rébellion mais à kadfi nous n'avons pas
levé le petit doigt nous n'avons nous ne
sommes pas intéressé à la population
civile de cette ville de CIRC j'éta en
Libye donc je sais de quoi je
parle et
euh aujourd'hui euh je suis allé je suis
allé euh à Bagdad et à Tripoli depuis
les interventions des Occidentaux et je
je n'ai pas trouvé une famille je n'ai
pas trouvé une famille qui ne regrettait
pas le régime ancien parce que certes
elle me disait que sous les régimes
anciens on ne pouvait pas faire de la
politique on ne pouvait pas aller dans
une réunion librement des républicains
comme je le fais aujourd'hui on risquait
de se faire fusiller à la sortie mais on
nait pas peur quand on envoyait ses
enfants à l'école et donc je pense que
la deuxième condition c'est que
puisqu'on intervient pour protéger les
popul civile avant d'intervenir
sommes-nous sûr de pouvoir leur
garantir que leur situation sera
meilleure après notre intervention
militaire qu'avant on ne peut pas leur
promettre qu'on va faire de de la Syrie
de la de de la Libye de l'Irak la Suisse
ou la Suède non est-ce que nous sommes
prêts à leur garantir que leur situation
sera meilleure après notre intervention
qu'avant ça c'est ma deuxème condition
et ma TR condition monsieur le ministre
c'est quand un leader qui s'appelle Tony
Blair Nicolas Sarkozy George W Bush
lance une opération extérieure
d'ingérance au nom des droits de l'homme
il est tenu de
ménager les intérêts à moyen et long
terme du pays qu'il sert puisque après
tout il fait ça avec le sang de ses et
l'argent des
contribuables alors on comprend bien que
Tony Blair il avait tout réussi il avait
été réussi réélu trois
fois l'économie marchait très bien en
Grande-Bretagne mais il était pas surcil
il était pas surcil alors il a lancé
l'invasion de l'Irak en 2003 la question
que je pose c'est Tony Blair a-t-il
ménagé les intérêts à moyen et long
terme de la Grande-Bretagne en Orient la
réponse est évidente c'est non et donc
euh notre politique libienne et
j'accepte bien sûr j'en ai déjà parlé
avec le président Sarkozy sa réponse de
dire que en 2012 la nouvelle
administration française n'a rien fait
pour la continuation l'accompagnement en
Libye mais pour pour le service
aprèsvente pour le service àprèsvente
mais l'opération d'avoir viré kadfi par
la force a-t-elle ménagé les intérêts à
moyen et long terme de la France dans
cette région du monde la réponse est non
nous avons déstabilisé nous avions été
conseillés d'ailleurs avertis par les
présidents des pays sahéiens qui sont
nos amis le Niger le Mali et cetera nous
avons déstabilisé toute la région du
Sahel nous avons c'est bien plus grave
aujourd'hui k Dessi m'a dit le président
tunisien que
il était extrêmement déstabilisé par
l'État islamique qui s'était implanté à
Sabrata juste à côté de la Tunisie donc
la Tunisie qui est un très vieil allié
est aujourd'hui déstabilisé par la
situation en Libye alors sur je vais
être obligé de vous demander de conclure
monsie je vais conclure je vais conclure
très très
simplement mais on a bien compris les
trois
conditions
je demande juste une conclusion madame
parce que je suis je suis obligé
d'organiser je vais je vais tout est
important je vais conclure je vais
conclure je vais conclure en disant que
lorsqu'on prend une décision je vais
conclure quand on prend une décision
d'intervention extérieure il y a un
point de forme et un point de
fond le point de forme c'est que il ne
faut pas décider en politique étrangère
et c'est très
important faut pas décider sous le coup
de l'émotion donc il faut séparer
l'émotion de la décision stratégique
voilà ça c'est la première chose et donc
quand vous prenez une politique de
politique étrangère vous devez pas faire
ça sous la pression des médias surtout
pas bien réfléchir et consulter
consulterz vos alliés ça c'est sur
excusez-moi monsieur le ministre vous
avez beaucoup parlé pend ça je fais
juste ma deuxè ma deuxème conclusion sur
sur
le je fais juste je fais juste sur je
fais juste sur sur sur le fond
simplement sur le fond je pense que nous
devons notre politique étrangère nous
n'avons pas vocation à moraliser le
monde nous avons renoncé à la mission
civilisatrice de la colonisation dont
parlait Jules Ferry volontairement nous
n'avons pas vocation à mettre notre
système français dans le monde entier la
démoc tie à la française dans le monde
entier ce que nous avons fait à faire
c'est à être un exemple chez nous pour
défendre nos valeurs et que par
l'exemple nous nous imposions à
l'extérieur et donc je pense que nous
nous nous trompons d'époque lorsque nous
voulons dire nous allons remplacer
Bachar
al-Assad en en Syrie quand Hollande a
voulu lui faire la guerre en au mois
d'août 2013 cétait une erreur par qu'il
l'aurait remplacé Bachar alAssad et donc
je pense qu'il faut être exemplaire chez
nous et c'est notre exemplarité qui qui
fera répandre nos valeurs et qui sera à
la base d'une bonne politique étrangère
française de Gaul a pu faire une bonne
politique étrangère parce qu'il avait
rétabli l'ordre à la maison je vous REM
merci beaucoup Monsieur
Girard vous avez beaucoup de succès tant
mieux
mes chers amis il nous reste il nous
reste 15 petites minutes puisque Nicolas
Sarkozi arrive à midi deux intervenants
15 divis par 2 ça fait 7 et demi
Monsieur Michel Duclot directeur général
de l'Académie diplomatique
internationale va nous dire quelques
mots sur la dissuasion nucléaire le
contre-terrorisme et puis on pose cette
question comment gagner la guerre contre
le djihadiste c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment très compliqué d'en parler en
quelques minutes mais quand même merci
pour votre
éclairage merci je je je traiterai pas
le sujet naturellement je je dirais
quelques mots et évidemment moi je me
situe sur un plan différent parce que
j'ai une je suis un diplomate j'ai passé
46 ans au k d'orsé j'ai servi dans
beaucoup de pays notamment en Syrie et
et je dois vous dire que je partage pas
la vision qui vient d'être présentée
maintenant par euh par Renaud Girard
je crois qu'en plus sur le plan
intellectuel il faut faire attention à
pas tout
mélanger l'intervention en Irak c'était
une intervention de choix comme le
disent les Américains euh qui était
effectivement une une impulsion de de
bouche que que rien ne l'obligeait à à
faire euh l'intervention en Libye euh
c'était autre chose
l'intervention en Syrie elle n'a pas eu
lieu et donc tous les gens qui disent on
est méchant parce queon intervient
partout justement en Syrie on n'est pas
intervenu alors sur la Libye je
laisserai Nicolas Sarkozi se se
présenter sa propre vision moi je crois
honnêtement que si Kaddafi n'était pas
parti nous aurions des problèmes du même
ordre actuellement en Libye il ne faut
pas croire que si nous avions laissé si
nous avions laissé fi continuer à
assassiner son peuple ça aurait été
beaucoup mieux pour nos intérêts
français d'ailleurs nous avons laissé
Assad assassiner son peuple et on peut
pas dire que la région s'enorte mieux et
que nos intérêts soit préservé voilà
peut-être un premier point le deuxième
point c'est que pour répondre ns pas à
la question mais une partie de la
question ce qui est vrai c'est que
tout miser sur l'intervention militaire
ce n'est pas une solution et que du
surcroix ça déplace notre image auprès
des peuples et des pays de la région et
que ce que nous devons faire dans les
dans les mois et les années qui viennent
c'est retrouver une capacité d'influence
et surtout une capacité d'agir en
médiateur la capacité médiatrice de la
France ça c'est quelque chose que qui
est importante qui est important pour
pouvoir agir c'est une des conditions
pour pouvoir agir contre le le
terrorisme vouz que je m'arrête là ou
que je j'explique en vous avez encore
une minute prenez encore une minute mes
chers amis le les républicains c'est un
parti où on débat et je pense que c'est
très intéressant d'avoir des éclairages
différents après chacun se fait sa
propre opinion c'est très important
d'accepter que nous entendions des des
des avis qui sont pas forcément les les
mêmes alors je vais peut-être continuer
à ce moment-là à contrarier le le public
en disant que pour trouver cette
capacité
de d'influence et de et de et de
médiation dans cette région il faut pas
céder à l'illusion de croire qu'on peut
changer d'alliance c'est-à-dire passer
des Saoudiens aux Iraniens ou des
Américains au russes certes il faut
travailler avec les Russes et certes il
faut travailler avec les Iraniens mais
c'est pas en bazardant nos anciens
alliés qu'on aura de la crédibilité
vis-à-vis des gens avec lesquels nous
voulons établir un dialogue plus plus
étroit je peux m'arrêter là si vous
voulez merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir accepté aussi peu de de temps de
de parole merci beaucoup pierre c'est à
toi pour la conclusion
de cette matinée avant que Nicolas
arrive merci c'est une sorte de tour de
force que d'essayer de faire rentrer en
un tout petit nombre d'heures autant de
sujets et on a vu que chacun de ces
sujets fait l'objet de vra de vraies
discussions c'est exprès que j'ai voulu
mettre un thème qui s'appelait le
dilemme des interventions extérieures et
c'est exprès que j'ai fait venir des
gens qui pensent pas la même chose parce
que c'est un vrai sujet il y a des
endroits on est allé d'autres endroits
on on n pas voulu aller par exemple en
Syrie euh ou alors on y va mal comme en
ce moment avec Hollande comme supplétif
des États-Unis il y a des endroits où on
est allé en prétextant qu'il y avait une
invasion de bamaco au Mali alors qu'il y
avait pas d'invasion de bamaco mais on a
quand même nettoyer le nord Mali mais on
n'a pas réglé le problème du Mali du
coup on est parti dans une intervention
encore plus large derrière barcan sans
ligne de sortie donc la question de
savoir comment est-ce que dans un monde
bouleversé autour de nous on utilise la
force alors qu'on l'a jamais autant
utilisé que ce gouvernement socialiste
comme d'ailleurs à chaque fois qu'il a
les socialistes on on multiplie le le
nombre de fronts les socialistes adorent
faire la guerre c'était vrai avant la
deuxième guerre mondiale c'est vrai
aujourd'hui c'était vrai pendant la
phase coloniale et Ren Girard rappelle
Jul ferry la mission colonisatrice
l'aventure coloniale dont nous payons
les retombées ici et là-bas aujourd'hui
c'est quand même nos amis de gauche qui
l'ont inventé c'est pas les
conservateurs de droite c'est il faut
savoir ce genre de chose mais bon je
veux pas revenir sur ce qui a été dit je
voudrais essayer de faire une synthèse
de ce qui s'est dit ce matin euh avant
le discours de Nicolas euh et peut-être
pour éclairer au fond les les grands
défis qui attendent la France euh dès
l'année prochaine si comme je l'espère
nous avons une alternance et et j'ai
euh j'ai euh j'ai énuméré
euh j'ai listé
et je vais aller très vite huit grands
défis qui sont en face de nous et c'est
une sorte de shopping list que je vais
vous donner en insistant peut-être sur
les deux derniers points c'est-à-dire la
Russie et la Turquie il y a au moins
trois grands dossiers économiques qui
sont autant de défis pour nous le
premier c'est le dossier des relations
commerciales avec nos voisins européens
et surtout avec les États-Unis c'est ce
qu'on appelle le traité transatlantique
et derrière le traité transatlantique
c'est espèce de rouleau compr presseur
normatif américain qui déroule par le
biais de l'extraterritorialité des lois
américaines et toujours au nom des
grands sentiments des meilleurs
sentiments la lutte contre la corruption
la lutte contre la la fraude
fiscale la la bonne concurrence des des
entreprises un un un système qui permet
aux agences de renseignement américaines
mais aussi à la justice américaine au
SBI de faire la police à l'intérieur de
nos entreprises aujourd'hui c'estàd que
prenez l'exemple de l'Iran mais j'ai
j'ai pas le temps mais si vous prenez
que l'exemple de l'Iran aujourd'hui où
théoriquement les sanctions sont levées
depuis un an aucune entreprise française
peut travailler en Iran parce que il y a
pas de financement et pourquoi il y a
pas de financement parce que la chambre
de compensation de New York n'a pas levé
l'embargo sur l'utilisation du dollar
donc on peut pas financer la vente
d'avion ou la vente d'automobile Peugeot
en Iran 1 an après la levée des
sanctions je pourrais continuer comme ça
longtemps la corruption c'est formidable
ça sert aussi d' argument pour prendre
le contrôle d'entreprise française ou
les pénaliser lurdement la BNP quand
même 10 milliards d'euros pour avoir
contourné un embargo que nous n'avions
pas déclaré sur le Soudan ou sur Cuba 10
milliards d'euros 10 milliards d'euros
c'est la somme avec laquelle une autre
entreprise américaine General Electric
s'est offert al stock voilà le genre de
problématique économique qui sont devant
nous et moi je ne suis pas de ceux qui
sont résignés à
subir deè deuxème système le système
financier international Nicolas Sarkozi
président et président de l'Europe et je
m'en souviens très bien en 2008 a eu
affaire à quasi effondrement du système
financier international si vous croyez
que le problème est derrière nous il est
pas du tout derrière nous et les Goldman
sax de la terre continuent à utiliser
des produits pourris et à se les refiler
d'un côté à l'autre avec une très grande
fragilité du système financier
international c'est pas réglé et il
serait peut-être temps de faire quelque
chose dans ce domaine pour l'instant
silence radio du côté du gouvernement
français 3ème volet alors la interne
c'est la zone euro là encore
l'expérience de Sarkozi en 2008 les
fondrement de la zone euro la zone euro
elle est en fait divisée en deux à cause
de
l'étogénéité des puissances européennes
certaines sont très puissantes comme les
l'Allemagne d'autres sont très faibles
comme la Grèce pour l'instant ça tient
parce que
dragy après la période austère de
tricher drag qui garantit les dettes
mais enfin il y a de plus en plus de
voir en Allemagne qui disent ça suffit
la zone euro c'est pas une zone de
transfert où les l'épargne allemande va
financer ADV vitam etternal la Grèce
donc il y a il y a un problème de
devenir de la zone euro qui n'est pas
réglé et ça fait partie voilà trois
défis
économiques considérables pour les
années qui viennent et auxquels nous
aurons à faire face en matière de
sécurité trois grands défis aussi j'en
ai touché un mot tout à l'heure quand je
vous ai montré la carte du proch-orient
comment est-ce qu'on recoue le
Proche-Orient comment est-ce qu'on
recoue l'Irak sachant que l'Irak a déjà
éclaté en trois morceaux les Kurdes les
chiites au sud les sunnites qui sont
aujourd'hui sous le contrôle de daesh
comment est-ce qu'on refait une Syrie
est-ce qu'on peut redessiner le proche
orient aujourd'hui personne ne réfléchit
à ça je vous assure au Cadoré on est
dans la gestion du court terme la France
n'a pas l'ombre d'un début d'idée sur
comment il faut faire pour le Proche
Orient et la question fondamentale effec
que que Michel duclo vient de dire
savoir comment est-ce qu'on joue entre
la tension entre l'Arabie Saoudite et
l'Iran qui se font la guerre par
coopération est fondamental prenez le
Liban aujourd'hui le Liban ça fait 2 ans
qu'il n'a plus de président 2 ans qu'il
n'a pas d'assemblée nationale la
situation économique est tragique et il
y a 2 millions de réfugiés pourquoi
est-ce qu'il y a pas de président parce
que l'Arabie Saoudite et l'Iran s'oppose
pour la désignation du président
chrétien donc là il y a clairement et je
l'ai dit hier à jean-mar Marot plutôt
que d'organiser de la diplomatie
hôtelière sur des sujets qu'on sait pas
réglé par exemple le conflit
israëlo-palestinien ça sert à rien de
réunir 28 personnes ici à Paris pour
pour dire on peut pas avancer autant
faire une initiative diplomatique de la
France pour essayer entre saoudiens
iranien de donner un président au Liban
parce que sinon ce pays est condamné
deuxième chose je reviens du Kurdistan
iraakien les pêchmerga sont les seuls
les seuls vous m'entendez à se battre
contre daesh les seuls ils ont
1800000 réfugiés iraakiens aujourd'hui
au Kurdistan or il faut savoir que
Bagdad a coupé les vivres donc il y a
pas un centime qui arrive à herbil il
faut savoir que le prix du pétrole a
chuté de moitié donc ce pays est livré
tout seul c'est le seul qui se bat donc
on envoie des quelques armes on envoie
des forces spéciales mais zéro aide
économique qu'attend la France pour
obtenir du FMI des lignes de crédit pour
aider ce pays à faire la guerre contre
daesh là aussi aucune réponse du
gouvernement français euh deuxième grand
défi stratégique c'est ce qu'on c'est ce
qui a été dit sur l'Afrique sahélienne
avec toute la problématique et du
recentrage notre aide au développement
et euh du du rôle de nos de nos armées
c'est un vrai sujet sur lesquel là
encore on na viig à vu il y a pas de
solution trisème grand grand défi de
sécurité je le mentionne au passage mais
on y a beaucoup travaillé ces derniers
temps à l'Assemblée c'est tout ce qui
touche à la coopération anti-terroriste
en Europe il est pas possible il n'est
pas possible d'accueillir
1800000 étrangers sans contrôle en
Europe l'année dernière et de prétendre
se battre contre le terrorisme alors
qu'il n'y a aucun contrôle la liberté de
circulation elle est totale pour les
terroristes totale et aujourd'hui aucun
des systèmes qui est censé fonctionner
le le sis2 Schengen Eurodac le contrôle
ôle des papiers aucun de ces systèmes ne
fonctionne donc c'est le marché commun
des terroristes en ce moment en Europe
ça n'est pas tenable il faut absolument
que nous soyons Capa et quand Nicolas
Sarkozi dit il faut un deuxème Schengen
il a raison on ne pourra pas lutter
contre le
terrorisme si on ne met pas sérieusement
en place des systèmes de contrôle
d'autant que avec les progrès de la
coalition en ce moment en Syrie en Irak
vous allez avoir le retour de plus
milliers de combattants extrêmement
aguéris et fanatisés et qui vont revenir
en Europe qui sont autant de bombes à
retardement j'en viens à
[Applaudissements]
mon dans les 3 minutes Nicolas que je
que je que je garde avant ton
discours
je voudrais dire je voudrais dire je
vais évoquer trois thèmes pour pour
conclure le premier rendez-vous que nous
allons avoir dès la semaine prochaine
c'est le devenir de l'Union
européenne le référendum britannique
arrive le 23 et le 24 on sera dans une
autre phase de la construction
européenne et à partir de ce moment-l il
faudra que la France se rappelle qu'elle
est le pays fondateur de l'Union et
qu'ell soit capable de prendre des
initiatives avec le gouvernement actuel
très honnêtement j'en doute mais il faut
que nous soyons capables de tracer les
pistes d'un avenir
européen décider si nous sortons nous
aussi si la mode est à la sortie ou bien
si nous restons dans quelles conditions
nous allons rester et ça c'est un vrai
sujet je crois que je crois savoir que
le président Sarkozi il a un peu
réfléchi mais en tout cas en ce moment
on est vraiment devant un risque à la
fois de fragmentation et de paralysie
fragmentation on le voit bien sur
l'immigration entre l'Est et l'Ouest
fragmentation nord- sudud sur l'économie
à la monnaie et de paralysie on la vit
tous les jours donc il faut en sortir et
cette ce référendum britannique si nous
sommes capables d'utiliser sa force doit
nous permettre de sortir de cette
crise deux réflexions enfin deux sujets
que je voudrais évoquer en deux phrases
parce qu'on a plus le temps le premier
c'est la relation avec la Russie
président il aura l'occasion ce soir
d'en parler avec le président russe je
vais vous dire la seule chose dans
l'Europe n'est pas besoin aujourd'hui
c'est d'une nouvelle guerre froide on a
suffisamment d'ennui avec le sud de
l'Europe pour se payer le luxe d'un
sommet de l'OTAN début juillet qui voit
arriver des missile antimissile des
nouvell unité de combat la reconduction
des sanctions à l'égard de la Russie sur
l'Ukraine nous sommes devenus les otages
de nos propres sanctions c'est quand
même malheureux à dire mais il y a
aucune raison que la rad vote les lois
de décentralisation pour permettre la
réunification du dambas et du Louang
avec le maintien des sanctions donc il
faut que nous arrivions à un calendrier
et ça c'est le rôle de la diplomatie
française qui permette le vote de la loi
par la Rada ukrainienne le retrait des
soldats russes et l'insertion de moyens
de l'OSCE rapidement et c'est faisable
c'est faisable parce que les Russes
veulent sortir c'est c'est faisable
parce que ces sanctions sont inutiles et
dangereuses donc il faut en sortir je
redis que les Russes aujourd'hui ont un
problème qui est exactement le même que
le nôtre en Syrie en Irak il y a 4000
4000 citoyens russes surtout des
tchetchenenes et des gens du Caucase qui
se battent aujourd'hui en Irak et en
Syrie il y a 4000 européens Nicolas en
Irak et en Syrie ça ça fait un intérêt
stratégique commun majeur entre la
Russie et l'Europe ça veut pas dire
Michel qu'il fa changer d'alliance mais
ça veut dire qu'on doit pas se laisser
entraîner dans une nouvelle guerre
froide qui n'est pas de notre intérêt
stratégique je le dis tout à fait
clairement un dernier mot sur un sujet
sur lequel Nicolas et moi au fil des
années on a beaucoup parlé je parlais de
la de la Turquie et je dois dire avec
beaucoup de modestie que si quelqu'un
avait vu juste depuis le début sur
monsieur Erdogan il s'appelle Nicolas
[Applaudissements]
SAR je le dis avec beaucoup de modestie
parce que moi j'ai toujours pensé que
Turquie et l'Europe c'est qu'un sièclle
d'histoire c'est pas
rien l'Europe a été dominée par l'empire
Ottoman pendant 7 ou siècl depuis le 14e
siècle l'Empire ottoman domine toute la
Méditerranée donc il a une longue
histoire il y a une longue histoire
depuis même François 1 à l'époque où la
NA la marine turque est passé l'hiver à
Toulon et à Villefranche surmer quand
quand nous faisions la guerre ensemble
contre les austroongrois aujourd'hui on
est dans un autre monde on a
malheureusement une Turquie qui en
partie est occidentale l'autre partie
est en train de dériver vers vers vers
l'islamisme vers une
politique de plus en plus que
j'appellerai national ottomane
islamiste et qui nous fait payer très
cher à nous Européens nos
faiblesses l'accord passé par Madame
marquel avec Monsieur Erdogan va nous
coûter très cher parce que par nos
propres faiblesses nous avons remis les
clés des frontières extérieures de
l'Union à la Turquie et qui nous le fait
payer et qui nous montre d'ailleurs que
quand la Turquie veut fermer le robinet
à immigré elle ferme le robinet à
immigré quand elle veut l'ouvrir ça se
traduit par le 18ion800000 personnes que
n avons accueilli dû accueillir l'an
dernier donc je crois qu'il faut que
nous soyons capable à la fois de
restaurer le dialogue mais avec
énormément de fermeté la levée des visas
qui doit arriver j'ai interrogé hier
Nicolas le ministre des affffaires
étrangères qui était d'ailleurs fort
embarrassé j'ai dit mais attendez il
devait pas y avoir une levée des visas
là sur la Turquie ce mois-ci au mois de
juin il m'a dit dit bon ben c'est pas
complètement prêt mais peut-être et
cetera euh 6 milliards d'euros la levée
des visas pour 80 millions de turqu plus
la reprise des négociations au moment où
la Turquie s'assoie sur toutes les
règles de de de de liberté à l'intérieur
de la presse des partis politiques et
Durc le ton sur la la totalité des
sujets y compris en Irak Syrie où elle
joue ses propres intérêts c'est un vrai
sujet on peut plus continuer à avoir une
Turquie qui laisse passer librement
d'Ouest en Est les djihadistes vers la
Syrie et de l'autre côté les migrants
d'est en ouest donc c'est un vrai sujet
pour nous dans les années qui viennent
voilà Nicolas nous avons beaucoup
travaillé je crois bien travaillé ce
matin je crois que la convention était
d'un vrai bon
niveau je crois que tu peux en être
raisonnablement satisfait on n pas des
réponses sur tous les sujets mais au
moins je crois qu'avec avec Alain
jyandet avec tous ceux qui ont participé
Philippe Cochet les ambass ur les les
les gens de l'extérieur les gens de
l'intérieur on a eu je crois un très
très bon débat et c'est avec plaisir
monsieur le Président que je te passe la
parole